[Musique]
c'est quelle couleur ça arrêtez de faire
ça d'abord parce que ça donne
l'impression qu'on est un fric qu'on a
regardé dans sa cage à la fois puis
parce que 9 fois sur 10 vous montrer une
bouteille de coca et on sait tous que
c'est rouge quand on a la bonne réponse
on enchaîne quasiment à tous les coups
sur bah tu vois les couleurs tu es pas
daltonien suivant le type de daltonisme
on les voit pas toutes ou on distingue
pas toutes les nuances où on en confond
certaines bah c'est pas dur quand tu
vois rouge tu dis que c'est vert
là tu viens de changer la vie de tous
les daltoniens du monde quand un
daltonien voit une couleur parfois il
voit la bonne parce qu'elle est située
dans le spectre où il a pas de problème
parfois il voit la mauvaise parce
qu'elle est située sur mauvais spectre
c'est pas vert égale rouge et rouge
égale vert mais tu vois comment en fait
un daltonien il voit comme il a toujours
vu donc il a aucun élément de
comparaison qui proposent de montrer
comment on voit les différents types de
daltoniens mais bon